c'est toujours comme ça un enfant dans
son monde s'invente des histoires avec
des voitures un garage l'homme qui parle
à l'enfant a passé toute sa vie à
imaginer des jeux des jouets les jouets
avec lesquels jouent l'enfant en 1970 on
appelait cela crée bernard était encore
étudiant je travaille pour hachette
auriez le premier jeu de d'édition
hachette et il faut le pousser pour un
jeu faut deux ans de mise au point entre
la création la mise au point et jusqu'à
la commercialisation
donc voyez c'était des jeux pour faire
des tableaux de composition les
différentes couleurs
oui la dînette qui a été relooké comme
on dit dans notre jargon sur la ville
impériale de châteauroux voyez donc ici
vous avez le tout la petite table et de
napoléonienne la maison de george sand
en briques de construction made in
france est lassé des premiers pousseurs
de chercher aujourd'hui bernard n'a plus
d'ateliers pour réaliser ces maquettes
il travaille à son bureau sur
l'ordinateur pour la 2d et avec un
prestataire local pour réaliser ces
prototypes avec une imprimante 3d les
pousseurs c'est l'un de ses plus beaux
succès on a été vraiment les pionniers
les leaders dans presque dans le monde
entier dans ce domaine là d'ailleurs
j'étais beaucoup on a été beaucoup
copiée que ce soit les arceaux de
sécurité les basculer tout donc voyez ça
a été un est un succès depuis de
nombreuses années bernhard langer à le
jouer souriant l'oeil rieur
il a imaginé des cuisines quelquefois de
véritables cuisines de restaurant avec
la lumière le sombre et cuisson le
fourneau celle ci a impressionné le
salon de new york au début de ce siècle
bernard a inventé des circuits pour les
majorettes des garages écolo où l'enfant
recharges les voitures à la manivelle
des fermes en matériaux recyclables pour
oublier le plastique aujourd'hui
l'enfant de châteauroux est plutôt
consultants et il regarde ses cinquante
années de jouer avec un sourire